today the department of health and human
services
is issuing an epidemic order to resume
indoor dining on monday february 1st
i know this pandemic has hurt our
restaurant owners
our restaurant workers i want you to
know that i will continue to do
everything in my power to support you
and your families
michigan bars and restaurants are
getting ready to reopen for indoor
dining at 25
capacity next week now several big
cities and blue
states are announcing plans to lift
restrictions on
indoor dining just less than a week
after a change at the white house
indoor dining resumed saturday in
chicago and in washington d.c on friday
when nearby baltimore resumed indoor and
outdoor dining
power panel comes now fox news
contributor jessica tarlov
david webb host of the david webb show
on siriusxm's patriot channel also a fox
news contributor
jessica and david good to see you both
david i'm going to start with you
uh why now look at your watch what
changed
well what changed is i guess the
political calculus now matters
they made political decisions they
follow the science crew
and they told us they would follow it
well now they're following the democrat
political science
but the economics matter here 25
capacity is not enough to keep a
restaurant open
and maybe they didn't study business but
you need at least 30 to 40 percent
in the door just to open the doors
before you get to even the points of
profitability you have to maintain
then you have to be profitable so this
is really a failure by these liberal
decisions
liberal mayors liberal governors in a
successful effort to remove president
trump
and hurt republicans while they
destroyed lives from a health
perspective
and livelihoods from a business
perspective all around america
jessica you know i i'm looking um
we we are we are in a world of hurt
right now i mean the numbers are
are yeah just heartbreaking for covid
so but you want to reopen in those blue
states and big cities
now not you personally but those
governments those those leaders
what is happening i say look at your
watch what changed
because it's only getting worse right
now they're not able to put as many
shots in arms as as
we need to no absolutely and i know that
the biden administration is fully
focused on
ensuring that we do meet that million
vaccinations a day planned so that we
can get to 100 million
in the first one actually you're
absolutely right we're losing around
4 500 americans each day icu's are
packed
but i was looking at what's been
released from governor newsom's office
for instance and they are looking at
projections
for hospitalizations over the next month
this is information that hasn't been
made publicly available yet
but that's what they're going on that is
good news if these vaccinations are
moving us
closer to a place where we can be doing
things like dining but
hospitalizations were lower the closures
are right
walking around to see this but i would
add that like in new york city for
instance
indoor dining shut down on december 11th
well over a month
after president trump legally and
lawfully lost the election so this
wasn't something that's happening
necessarily in these big blue cities and
states
just because they wanted to give biden a
pat on the back they did this in
december
and later in november so it wasn't about
the election
david yeah jessica doesn't follow the
facts very well in this first of all
calculations for icu beds except for
community hospitals
is based on available staff if a staff
member gets sick on that floor
they remove the staff that reduces
capacity that's actually how you account
for beds
so when they told us capacity was down
it was actually not down
conversely when you look at infections
and recoveries
the data contradicts that they made bad
decisions
deadly decisions in some cases not
following both the facts the economics
and the data
and now you're right harris when the
trajectory is different
well biden comes out and says where you
remember the dark winter he's not going
to shut down the economy
he's going to shut down the virus well
biden
just said it's on the front page of fox
news that this
is going to continue the pandemic
trajectory is wrong
so come on tell me which one and as far
as the million shots
100 million doses i had this discussion
on august 20th with the vice president
after numerous interviews with members
of the task force this plan was laid out
but biden said he didn't inherit a plan
the plan has issues
but there's been a plan because you
didn't accidentally get over 36 million
doses in arms
well look i mean we were close we were
above 500 000 doses in arms when
president trump was rolling this out in
the beginning
yes woefully short of where we need to
be but now
if you're shooting for a million you're
still woefully short of where we need to
be